If climate change were
an animal or plant,
I think it would be
some sort of parasite,
because it's the only thing
that's actually growing
and getting bigger,
while everything else
starts dying off.
The environment
is definitely very special
because if we get rid of it,
there's nowhere else we can go.
It's a very one in a million planet.
A 10-year-old some years ago
got cross with me
and said, "You don't get it."
He said, "You grew up thinking that
polar bears would be there forever."
He said, "I've grown up
knowing they will go extinct."
I don't remember
when I first became aware
about climate change. I don't
remember a time where I didn't know
what it was. It feels like
it's always been there.
Children are growing up
with this knowledge
and this awareness, whereas anyone
over the age of, let's say 30,
is having to wake up to this
and realise it.
When we asked young people about
how climate change made me feel,
three-quarters or more,
think the future is frightening.
So we know that it's having
an emotional impact on children
and young people
all around the world.
I think climate change
is really scary.
And the fact that lots of people
aren't doing much about it,
just sort of freaks me out.
Eight out of 10 told us
that people had failed to
take care of the planet.
So this is young people
and children looking to adults,
looking to older people,
looking to people in power,
and saying, "Why haven't you
done something about this?"
It makes me feel angry
to see such a clear issue
and to see everyone
knowing about this issue,
and still not doing anything
that they really should be.
It's just frustrating.
And I think it's also tiring
to feel so scared and angry.
One of the worst things
we can do to children
and young people is say, "Well,
it's your responsibility now."
I've heard this said to children.
"Your generation will fix this.
Your generation is so inspiring
and creative and innovative.
We're going to leave this to you
to fix."
There is an idea by older people
that it is on young people
to fix it.
But I think that's really unfair,
and I think it's a collective
responsibility,
not just on young people
and not just on me.
One of
the most worrying statistics
was that 48% told us
they were dismissed or ignored
when they tried to talk about
climate change.
That, we could do something about
this afternoon.
That, we could do
something about today.
In places like school, I feel
like they don't really listen,
and don't really respect the fact
that I've thought about it
and tried to educate myself
about it.
I kind of feel really angry
and frustrated,
because I am actually
saying something meaningful.
And if you're not prepared
to listen to your children,
it's going to have a big effect,
because we actually
do have something to say, and we are
actually trying to make a change.
My advice to adults,
parents, teachers, is
do not put it off,
don't push it away.
Don't save it up and just have
that big conversation.
Talk about it regularly.
That's crucial.
And it's OK for you
to say to your children,
"I don't have all the answers.
We're not sure exactly
how to deal with all of this.
But let's find out together."